[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and I'm dressed for
time travel anybody else here dressed
for time travel tonight just in case it
works I want to go back to 1984 and
whisper in my ear that doing something
called the hole or software catalog is
not going to be a good idea don't do it
and they've got a great big advance and
then Britain at the time here is this
this is 84 and software at that time in
Britain was a cartridge of tape that you
hear was 8 inch floppies there was this
cartridge of tape so here's a book
telling all these amazing things you
could get that they couldn't get and
they've sent me around of the television
shows and it was Christmastime so they
wanted to do a ugly Christmas sweater
and they made this for me I probably had
faded jeans and it was a disaster top to
bottom if I could go back and undo that
I would undo that time doesn't work that
way but we keep wanting it to and along
that foundation and away is one kind of
workaround well if it's trouble to deal
with the past because we can't change it
trouble to deal with the future because
you can't really see what's coming just
to expand and now 10,000 years in each
direction it's not a problem anymore
right it's sort of working but the way
humans wrestle is the asymmetry of time
is one of the most interesting things we
do in every period of time of every
period of civilization figures different
ways to to deal with the problem and
this is where you want to have an
historian of science and historian of
the effects of science
on culture to help think about all that
and nobody is better at that than our
speaker James click thank you Thank You
Stuart
thank you people of the people of the
long now for having me here I'm not sure
I'm dressed for time travel we can turn
that off now I wanted I want to begin by
asking you to cast your mind back word
in time which which I know you can do
it's one of your superpowers let's say
it's the 1890s put yourselves in the
shoes of a young man trying to write a
book for the first time and here's the
man now you've seen other pictures of
this man but probably never without a
mustache he was named Herbert birdy
to his family but he preferred to be
known by his initials HG because that
seemed more dignified here he is at the
Normal School in London which later
became the Royal College of Science and
as you might guess from the picture he's
studying biology where the hot new thing
in the history of life is his Charles
Darwin and he's also fascinated by the
new geology as revealed by Charles Lyell
these two Charles's not by coincidence
are giving humanity a new view of the
eons of time stretching out behind them
anyway you are a very young HG Wells
planning you're planning your future
mustache and you have an idea for a
fantastic tale that takes place far in
the future you think of yourself as a
futurist though that's barely even a
word most ordinary people never even
think about the future or if they do
they regard it and I'm quoting HG now as
a sort of
and non-existence upon which the
advancing present will presently write
events you however are more creative
your forward-looking now just in terms
of storytelling technique Wells had a
technical problem nowadays I might a
writer might just tell the reader it's
the year of our Lord eight hundred and
two thousand seven hundred and one and
get on with the story but you couldn't
do that in the 19th century it was too
weird people couldn't wrap their minds
around it and by the way right around
the same time in 1889 Mark Twain had a
similar problem he needed to transport a
modern-day Connecticut Yankee back to
the time of King Arthur's Court so he
does it by beginning his tale with a
prologue titled a word of explanation in
this prologue a curious stranger strikes
up a conversation with the narrator and
says you know about transmigration of
souls do you know about transposition of
epics and bodies this is what we would
call nowadays mumbo jumbo but Mark Twain
couldn't use the word time-travel
because there was no such word there was
no such concept in case you don't
remember how the transposition of epochs
occurs in Connecticut Yankee the Yankee
gets hit on the head by a crowbar out
cold when he wakes up he's in a green
field looking up at a knight in shining
armor and now ensues my favorite
two-word bit of dialogue in the whole
time-travel literature the Connecticut
Yankee points to the horizon and says
Bridgeport
Camelot says the knife later when the
story ends
Mark Twain chickens out and he tells us
the whole thing was just a dream
so he missed his opportunity
how did Wells solve his narrative
problem well you already know he
invented a time machine it's famous so
can you visualize the time machine I'll
give you a second close your eyes if it
helps maybe you were picturing this the
plush red chair great spinning disc
colored lightbulbs but this is not a
tree Wells this time machine when you
consult the book you discover that Wells
hardly describes the machine at all
there's some fast verbal hocus-pocus and
an impression of shiny nickel and ivory
and brass rails and some screws to be
loosened with oil and a lever and a
saddle to sit on actually the time
machine is a fantastic ated bicycle
which makes sense Wells was a proud
bicyclist and he'd never seen a motor
car of course and so if the funny
baroque sled over wrote the original in
your brain it's probably because you saw
the 1960 Hollywood version directed by
George Powell
so this is raw taylor at the controls in
the book he's called only the time
traveller for so it will be convenient
to speak of him but in the movie he has
to have a name so he's called George
he turns the lever and he hurdles into
the future where he meets a futuristic
person called weena in the book weena is
a tiny creature here she turns out to be
Yvette Mimieux later Yvette married my
cousin Stanley but but that's that's
true but that's it but that's another
story
now you can see the georgian wiener
getting to know each other weena is
strangely ignorant of history George
says don't your people ever speak of the
past there is no past she says do they
wonder about the future there is no
future she lives in the now it seems and
HG Wells thought most of his
contemporaries did too they lived in the
now here we are a 21st century the
people of Wells as' distant future and
we are time travel experts we are
aficionados time travel is everywhere
it's in pop songs TV commercials it's in
the wallpaper
we've got time machines time gates
doorways windows not to mention time
ships and special closets DeLoreans
police boxes animated cartoons have been
doing time travel since 1925 in Felix
the Cat trifles with time
father time agrees to send the unhappy
Felix back to a faraway time inhabited
by cavemen and dinosaurs in a 1944
Looney Tunes episode Elmer Fudd dreams
his way into the future when you hear
the sound of the gong it will be exactly
2000 AD where a newspaper headline
reveals smellivision replaces television
then by 1960 rocky and his friends were
sending the dog mr. Peabody and his pet
boy Sherman through the wayback machine
to straighten out William Tell Calamity
Jane the next year Donald Duck made his
first trip into prehistory to invent the
wheel Homer Simpson you may remember
found an unusual device to use as a time
machine
right I
toaster and there's Peabody and Sherman
floating by
apparently time travel is so crowded by
this time it needs air traffic control
about five years ago China's State
Administration of radio film and
television officially denounced time
travel warning that these stories
interfere with history I'm quoting
casually make up myths have monstrous
and weird plots use absurd tactics and
even promote feudalism superstition
fatalism and reincarnation and they're
right in a way time travel is subversive
it's not just in popular culture either
physicists love to speculate speculate
about time travel neuroscientists
psychologists have created a whole field
of study called mental time travel or on
formal days
Kronus theisha philosophers when they
talk about the metaphysics of change and
causality can't help but start talking
about time travel and its paradoxes so
it's strange to realize that the concept
is barely more than a century old it
seemed strange enough to me to be worth
a book time travel feels like an ancient
tradition rooted in old mythologies like
gods
and dragons but but it isn't the
ancients imagined immortality and
rebirth and reincarnation and lands of
the dead but the idea of getting into a
machine or walking through a magic
portal or even getting whacked on the
head in order to travel to the future or
the past this was beyond their camp so
the obvious question was why why did it
take so long to invent time travel and
then why did it happen when it did
well a lot of things were happening all
at once at at the close of the 19th
century there was huge curiosity and
excitement about the wonders of progress
people had seen in their lifetimes the
coming of railroads the Telegraph all
the wonders of electricity in France a
product of this was Jules Verne and his
technological fantasies although he
never actually did time travel
then when the turn of the century
arrived the roll over of the calendar
day brought all kinds of speculation
about the turn of the next century the
year 2000 a great round number so people
imagined flying cars and space travel
and underwater golf and lots of other
wonderful stuff some of which we
actually have let me just show you this
one picture by way of example this is
this is one of a set of prints made to
imagine life in the year 2000 by a
french artist named jean-marc cote for
cigarette cards you can see it's a
schoolroom and printed books are being
fed through a sort of grinder and
converted into a form that can be
transmitted into the boys heads through
wires so this is a vision that you have
to admit has come true at least you know
in a certain way on the other hand we
also have an advanced that most
futurists were not able to imagine which
is girls in the classroom
so here's the thing technology advances
it changes the fabric of our world it
changes the way we live and these
changes come rapidly and this is so
normal and so self-evident that we tend
to forget it wasn't always like that but
of course it wasn't suppose you got in
your time machine and headed back to the
past and dropped in on some random
stranger let's say the Year 1500 and you
asked what do you suppose life will be
like for your grandchildren well they
think you are crazy the question
wouldn't make sense life for their
grandchildren was going to be the same
as life for them their life was the same
as life for their grandparents
Shakespeare scholars sometimes point out
there are a bunch of anachronistic
mistakes in his plays in in Julius
Caesar a clock strikes the hour of 3:00
when actually there were no mechanical
clocks in ancient Rome or for the next
thousand years so silly mistake right
but how could Shakespeare have known
that he had no conception the
technological progress has a history for
him the word anachronism literally
didn't exist then came that thing that
we call the Industrial Revolution and
steam engines and bicycles and
Telegraph's and electric lights and by
the end of the 19th century people
weren't just aware of changing
technology they were getting obsessed if
you remember Connecticut Yankee that's
actually the point of the book the whole
thing is a riff on the magic of
technological change the wizard of King
Arthur's Court
Merlin is an old fraud the real wizard
is our Yankee because he knows about
lightning rods and gunpowder and Mark
Twain as you may know was a total
enthusiast he was the first on his block
with the telephone he was the first
writer ever to use a typewriter he would
absolutely have loved the whole earth
catalogue a funny thing about the time
machine though is that it's not
interested in technology at all at least
apart from the machine in the title the
future isn't technologically advanced on
the contrary it's degenerate not only
don't they have electricity they've
forgotten about fire
luckily the time traveller brought some
matches the book was a huge bestseller
on both sides of the Atlantic and and
made Welles famous it was in the
category of fantastic yarn people
thought of Edgar Allen Poe and if you
read it now the time machine feels very
old-fashioned and then you realize that
the reason is it's because time-travel
doesn't yet exist and so before the
story can get started the whole concept
has to be explained very pedantically
the time traveler gathers all his
friends in the drawing room and he
pontificates he says you must follow me
carefully I shall have to controvert one
or two ideas that are almost universally
accepted the geometry for instance that
they taught you at school is founded on
a misconception
remember how you all learned his he
tells them there are three dimensions
length width and height well guess what
there's a fourth dimension too and the
fourth dimension is time the time
traveler explains through a natural
infirmity of the flesh we inclined to
overlook this fact but there is no
difference between time and any of the
three dimensions of space except that
our consciousness moves along it so
presumably you're thinking well duh of
course time is the fourth dimension
but in 1895 that would not have been the
normal reaction and it's not the
reaction of the Time Traveler's friends
in the drawing room
they say it's ridiculous the things of
mere paradox says what it's against
reason says another and the reviewer
said more or less the same thing the New
York Times said worth reading if you
like to read impossible yarns which is a
blurb I'd sort of like to have on one of
my books and most reviewers appreciated
the fantasy but the serious critic for
the tell Mel magazine wagged a stern
finger there is no getting into the
future except by waiting you can only
sit down and see it come by in Verity
there is no time traveler mr. Welles
save old Father Time himself instead of
being a fourth dimension of space-time
is perpetually travelling through space
remember it's 1895 so ten years later
Albert Einstein came along and basically
made the fourth dimension official he
explains time pretty much the way well
says time traveller did the difference
between Einstein and Welles being that
Welles was just kidding
he thought he was just making up
mumbo-jumbo waving hand waving to help
his story along and for the rest of his
life he was a great disappointment to
many time-travel fans who wanted more
from him in his old age he tried to
remember how this idea came to him he
said in the universe in which my brain
was living in 1879
there was no nonsense about time being
spaced or anything of that sort there
were three dimensions up and down fore
and aft and right and left and I never
heard of a fourth dimension until 1884
or thereabout and then I thought it was
a witticism now I'm not saying
that we need to trust wells in his post
facto introspection there was clearly
something in the air or something
something that everyone was breathing
including Wells and Einstein and anyway
Wells opened the floodgates he started
something and the many streams and
rivers of time-travel begin at this
point with the time machine and then
later came the pulp magazines that
sprung up in New York in the first
decades of the new century amazing
stories and wonder stories and there are
many heirs and successors many of them
are alive to this day and meanwhile off
somewhere else a great modernist
literature was being born which we don't
think of as time travel but which shows
a grown fascination and awareness that
time could be very very weird I'm
talking about Proust and Joyce and
Virginia Woolf they are all about time
time is their subject and time is being
manipulated in their work in new ways
proofs wrote near the end of his great
work the fact that we occupy an ever
larger place in time capital T is
something that everybody feels a larger
place in time we occupy that larger
place we embody time we take the past
and the future on board it's an odd
thing to say that everybody feels that
but it's true today isn't it so let me
ask you all a basic question I can
barely see you but I'm I'm going to ask
four hands anyway let's say you are
awarded the use of a time machine good
for one voyage safe return guaranteed
it's a return trip do you go to the
future or the past
future
past I think it looked like there was a
little more future in this crowd which
is a little unusual here's an answer
from here's an answer from Twitter via
Joyce Carol this is from Joyce Carol
Oates look how many time travel tropes
she's meant to squeeze into a hundred
and forty characters she didn't get the
grandfather when I started working on my
book I have to admit I assumed that most
people would automatically choose the
future and I assumed that I would go to
the future and Welles himself interested
though he was in the history of the
world never bothered sending his time
traveller back to check out the
dinosaurs or interview Shakespeare he
was a future guy all the way but of
course my assumption was completely
naive and and nowadays especially the
future is not as well it's not as shiny
and appealing as it once seemed it
didn't take long when you look at the
history of the time travel literature
for other writers to see the
possibilities of hurtling backward in
time and I don't mean getting bonked on
the head and wait waking up in Camelot
I'm Camelot I mean traveling freely to
times of your choosing one of the first
writers to explore retrograde time
travel was in the first years of the
20th century a younger friend of Welles
named e Nesbit II for Edith she was a
fellow forward-looking free-thinking
socialist in her book the story of the
amulet she sends a pack of child heroes
back to ancient Egypt and to Babylon and
to Atlantis not necessarily all real
places in it in it
this people are riding around on hairy
mammoths and so on in this cover drawing
you can see them checking out the money
at the British Museum which was London's
very own time portal without intending
to Nesbitt was inventing a time travel
sub-genre we can see it later includes
classics like Sherman a Peabody Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure it's fair to
say than that the history in this genre
isn't always reliable my own favorite
Peabody and Sherman episode is the one
where they meet Isaac Newton and Peabody
solemnly explains that Sir Isaac had a
brother named fig B who invented a
cookie so comically or not time travel
lets us have at least the illusion of
exploring a past that was once alive and
is now lost these stories let us feel
that the past is still there waiting for
us to come find it we get to exercise
muscles that we use whenever we whenever
we look at old photographs when we go to
museums when we collect antiques when we
investigate history I was struck by a
remark of the great German writer
seybolt
might it not be that we also have
appointments to keep in the past in what
has gone before and is for the most part
extinguished and must go there in search
of places and people who have some
connection with us on the far side of
time so to speak that's the impulse at
work here the past pulls at us we have
appointments there but it's just a
beginning because as soon as people
started imagining actual time travel
into the past
they came face to face with inescapable
problems
the famous paradoxes even Edith
Nesbitt's children saw this at one point
they meet Julius Caesar at his tent in
Gaul looking hungrily across the English
Channel for a new country to conquer and
they try to talk him out of it oh please
sir don't conquer Britain it's a poor
little place hardly worth your trouble
but this backfires they end up talking
him into it because after all that
really happened and you can't change
history this is a rule and of course all
rules are made to be broken and before
long we're all going back and we're
killing Hitler or worse meeting
ourselves selves plural because
multiplying selves is one of the things
time travel does along with revising
histories and bifurcating universes
here's a time here's an example of a
time travel time travel are meeting
themselves on the right I'm sure many of
you recognize Joseph gordon-levitt he is
Joe this is the 2012 movie looper by
Rhian John Rian Johnson Joe is a sort of
time-traveling hitman and and on the
Left Bruce Willis is also Joe only older
and wiser so they're meeting for the
first time young Joe has a few questions
as you can imagine an old Joe says I
don't want to talk about time travel
[ __ ] because we start talking about it
then we're gonna be here all day talking
about it and making diagrams with straws
so the internet being the internet it
took no time at all for people to make
diagrams with straws
meant to explain the movies very twisty
plot and that's an example but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna leave it up there
long enough for you to try to figure it
out we'll be here all day but here's
another diagram in the same family
this diagram was drawn with a pencil by
Robert Heinlein in 1940 or 41 to help
him help himself keep track of a story
he was writing sorry the title in his
mind was Bob's busy day which is a great
title but when the story was published
by astounding science fiction magazine
they titled it by his bootstraps and I
love this story I loved it when I was a
kid and I loved it all over again when I
reread it to work on this book part of
what's wonderful about it is that you
can see that it's still early days for
time-travel 50 years have gone by since
the time machine and pulp fiction
writers like Bob Heinlein pounding their
typewriters for peanuts trying to figure
out the rules the rules of the game and
you can watch their creative minds at
work by the way Heinlein got paid 70
dollars for this story it opens with a
man named Bob sitting in his room typing
his philosophy dissertation which is
apparently about the metaphysics of time
travel and behind him he suddenly hears
a voice saying don't bother with it it's
all hogwash and he turns around to see a
chap about the same size as himself and
much the same age maybe just a tiny bit
older with what looks like a three-day
growth of beard and a black eye and the
chap has apparently emerged from a hole
hanging
in the air and he opens a cupboard and
helps himself to Bob's gym and he says
just call me Joe
well we 21st century people are savvy
about this stuff and we see right away
what's going on but Bob is slow to catch
on Joe tells him the hole in the air is
a time gate he wants Bob to walk through
it into the future as they discuss it a
third man materializes and he bears a
sort of family resemblance to Bob and
Joe and he emphatically does not want
Bob to listen to Joe and then the phone
rings and it's a fourth man checking on
everyone's progress and hilarity ensues
we know that all the men are the same
but not everyone is in on the joke or
rather they are led in at different
times it's a it becomes a farce doors
slamming and Confused an angry
girlfriend and a hat that keeps getting
lost and found and lost again and
meanwhile Bob Heinlein who may think
he's just a hack writer without a lot of
pretensions is actually quite serious
and can't help but following where the
story leads which is into some deep
philosophical thickets is there one self
or are there many does the self have
continuity or is it created anew at
every instant this is a problem for us
back here in the real world where we
remember our younger selves who both are
and are not the person we've become and
even without time-travel we managed to
create alter egos and split
personalities and each of the Bob's in
this story had felt themselves to be the
one and only integrated continuous being
named Bob but they're forced to confront
the possibility that this is an illusion
that they're just making it up as they
go along that the self is a story
they're telling themselves and this
isn't the only problem
Heinlein also finds himself confronting
the issue of free will and determinism
he can't help it you might say as soon
as any of the Bob's go back to an
earlier day and relive an episode
they've already been through they're
bound to ask can't I do it differently
this time when Bob one is talking to Bob
to deja vu is inevitable he feels he's
reciting a script
he's on a treadmill and he can't get off
and he doesn't like it he tries to argue
with himself this is impossible
bob says to Bob you're telling me that I
did something because I was going to do
something and Bob replies well didn't
you you were there well we're not going
to solve this problem in one story and
also we're not going to solve it tonight
but time travel is heavily implicated
I'm going to say it's a tool we are
using collectively as a culture in an
investigation of freewill and faith and
the nature of the self the paradoxes of
memory we're still trying to learn what
time is which by the way I intend to
explain in a minute
but first here's one last time traveler
meeting himself
this is HG Wells again the older meeting
the younger this is a 1924 caricature by
max Beerbohm and I'll read you the
handwritten caption don't strain your
eyes it goes the young self says did you
ever manage to articulate the bones of
the micro glama fed lizard and the old
self says I'm not sure but I've
articulated the whole past of mankind on
this planet and the whole future too I
don't think you know very much about the
past do you it's all perfectly beastly
believe me but the future is going to be
perfectly splendid after a bit all right
so what is time well everyone knows what
time is also no one knows what time is
and this paradox was noticed by
Augustine in the fourth century and
people have been quoting him ever since
wittingly and unwittingly Augustine
wrote what then is time he wrote this in
Latin if no one asks me I know if I wish
to explain it to one that asks I know
not Isaac Newton said at the outset of
the Principia that everyone knew what
time was but then he proceeded to
rewrite what everyone knew a modern
physicist Sean Carroll says everyone
knows what time is it's what you find
out by looking at a clock he also says
time is the label we stick on different
moments in the life of the world
now physicists are the specialists we
tend to think should have the official
answer and they keep reverting to these
bumper-sticker definitions richard
fineman said time is what happens when
nothing else happens
which is sort of a wisecrack or is it
and John Archibald wheeler is supposed
to have said time is Nature's Way to
keep everything from happening all at
once but Woody Allen said that too
and wheeler admitted having found it
scrawled in a Texas men's room and then
Susan Sontag did the boys one better
time exists in order that everything
doesn't happen all at once and space
exists so that it doesn't all happen to
you when Augustine contemplated time one
thing he knew was that it was not a
space and yet Lord we perceive intervals
of times and compare them and say some
are shorter and others longer we measure
time he said though he had no clocks we
measure times as they are passing by
perceiving them but past which now are
not or the future which are not yet who
can measure you cannot measure what does
not yet exist
Augustine felt nor what has passed away
now it is of course we do measure time
we spend so much time measuring time
that we hardly have time for anything
else
Augustine would be surprised anyway we
keep asking what time is as if the right
combination of words could crack the
lock and let in the light we want a
fortune cookie definition a perfect
epigram Daniel Boorstin says time is the
landscape of experience
Nabokov says time is but memory in the
making Martin Heidegger says there is no
time
sometimes we say time is a river it
flows you can't step into the same one
twice if time is a river are we standing
on the bank watching it go by or are we
bobbing along in an episode of the
original Star Trek
Spock explains that there could be some
logic to the belief the time is fluid
like a river with currents eddies
backwash of course time is not a river
nor is it a road an arrow or a maze or a
tide or a thread or a ladder these are
metaphors Nabokov also said time is a
fluid medium for the culture of
metaphors Newton said authoritative Lee
the time flows but that too is just a
metaphor and he was just as likely to
represent time as a quantity if time is
a quantity we can store it up apparently
we save it we spend it we accumulated
and Bank it and we do all this quite
obsessively nowadays but the notion is
at least 400 years old
Francis Bacon 16 12 to choose time is to
save time unfortunately the corollary of
saving time is wasting it we go back and
forth between being times master and its
victim time is ours to use and then we
are at its mercy richard ii says i
wasted time and now doth time wasted me
for now hath time made me his numbering
clock so if you say that an activity
wastes time implying a substance in
finite supply and then you say that the
same activity fills time implying a sort
of container are you contradicting
yourself are you confused
are you committing a failure of logic
well none of those I think on the
contrary we are clever creatures when it
comes to time and we can keep more than
one idea in our heads and we know that
language is imperfect we know metaphors
are fluid we can occupy the time and
pass the time in the same breath we can
devour time or languish in it slow chapt
power lately it's become fashionable
among physicists to ask whether time is
even real I'll do air quotes whether it
exists the question is debated at
conferences and symposia and analyzed in
books but when a physicist says time
isn't real it's not the same as saying
unicorns aren't real you don't see
physicists throwing away their
wristwatches
it's a sort of code saying time isn't
real is a way of saying that our
perception of time is all wrong it's a
way of saying past and future are the
same mathematically speaking which
remember is just what the time traveller
tells his friends in the drawing room
and what Einstein began to explain a
decade later a few weeks before he died
Einstein put it this way in a letter to
a friend people like us who believe in
physics know that the distinction
between past present and future is only
a stubbornly persistent illusion but it
is stubbornly persistent time is an A in
eradicable part of the human experience
we remember the past we await the future
the physicists notes that we are
fallible creatures easily fooled not to
be trusted
our pre scientific ancestors experienced
the flat earth and the traveling Sun
could our experience of time be that
naive I don't think so I don't even
think I'm Stein
believe that it would be perverse in a
way for a scientist to believe that the
future is already complete locked down
tight no different from the past the
whole motivation for the scientific
enterprise though the prime directive is
to gain some control over the future
that were otherwise tumbling into blind
for me it comes down to this the
universe does what it does we perceive
change perceive motion and try to make
sense of a teeming blooming confusion
Augustine was right all along the modern
philosopher jr. Lucas and his treatise
on time and space comes back around
we cannot say what time is because we
know already and our saying could never
match up to all that we already know so
when we take stock when we set aside the
search for the perfect epigram or for
the perfect definition it turns out that
we do know a great deal we know that the
past is gone it's finished done and
dusted signed sealed and delivered it
receives from us in the rearview mirror
our access to it is compromised
we've got fading memories and crumbling
fossils we can argue about what happened
we know that eyewitnesses are unreliable
and records can be tampered with the
unrecorded past for us no longer exists
and the future is different the future
is yet to come it's open not everything
can happen but many things can the world
is still under construction what is time
things change and time is how we keep
track Stephen Hawking likes to speculate
about time travel as many physicists do
he likes to offer reasons it might be
possible and then on other days he likes
to prove that it's impossible
once he famously sent out invitations
for a party to be held in the past of
course nobody came
ergo Hawking said time travel is
impossible well it doesn't matter we
time travel in our brains and that's not
nothing our culture in the broadest
sense of that world of that word our
species wide distributed information
storage and transmission system is a
time machine
we are all time travelers now like it or
not we are Time Lords the English
novelist Ollie Smith says we're well
past the end of the century when time
for the first time
curved bent slipped flash forwarded and
flash back yet still heaps rolling along
we know it all now with our thoughts
traveling at the speed of tweet our
hundred and forty characters in search
of a paragraph
we're post history we're post mystery so
why do we need time travel when we
already travel through space so far and
so fast we need it for history for
mystery for nostalgia for hope to
examine our potential to explore our
memories to counter regret for the life
we live the one life one dimension
beginning to end we need time travel
because time is a bastard time is coming
for us
time is a jailer and an executioner and
our glorious future The Jetsons future
the limitless future the future imagined
in code Hays cigarette cards flying cars
the future of the futurists where did
that go well it's been four shortened
one of William Gibson's science fiction
--is-- characters said 15 years ago
fully imagined futures were the luxury
of another day one in which
now was of some greater duration we have
no future because our present is too
volatile the future stands upon the
present and the present is quicksand and
surely that's the point of this
organization the long now foundation to
recover the future before it slips away
we're coping with nostalgia for a
vanishing future we need preservationist
s-- for the future and if that isn't a
time travel paradox I don't know what is
Virginia Woolf
said that the past shelters us on one
side and the future on the other side we
need them both our entry into the past
and the future fleeting and imperfect as
it may be is what keeps us human thank
you
a question from livestream design Stein
ever meet Wells and did Wells have any
influence on Einstein were they aware of
it each other at all oh I so badly
wanted that to be true and I spent I did
spend some time mmm thinking about it
and hoping I could find some scrap of
some shred of evidence
Einstein you know is pretty
well-documented and I and we would know
if he had and also was so it was a while
before the time machine was translated
into German so so I'm gonna say no it
didn't work that way but but it I you
know I said they were breathing the same
air they really were in this world where
Einstein was being influenced by the
existence of electric clocks at railway
stations by by a recognition of
simultaneity that was created by the
electric telegraph so it didn't have to
happen and as I said Wells never
believed in it himself was doing
relativity he came up with this sort of
the the the train travel metaphor yeah
his trains and in the absence of trains
that might not have actually been for
him to think about it no that's right
and he needed the the idea of trains
going going past you at high velocity
that was that was also an influence on
Wells I mean Wells was living in in
Victorian England and and you could ride
a train and look out the window and see
a farmer with a plough behind an oxen
that was a scene that that existed 400
years earlier and you're gone zipping
past honest with a steam engine and you
can see telegraph wires across the
landscape and you have you experience a
kind of temporal dissonance that was
that was new
an analogue of cognitive dissonance and
and I think that's something that that
had to have affected both Welles and
Einstein and all the rest of them I mean
this is really the point not just these
two guys but that the whole culture was
very excitedly and very animatedly
thinking about time and getting confused
by it
why was the turn of that century and I
think the 20th all about the splendid
shiny progressed future and the turn of
the 20th century into the 21st was a lot
darker what's your sense of what
happened well that's that's a huge
question isn't it I mean why didn't we
have because we really didn't have I
mean occasionally there were a few
newspapers that thought okay we'll ask
some profound thinkers maybe they asked
you Stewart what do you what do you
expect for the year 2100 yeah
but the answers were sort of
disappointing and if you try to answer
that question in your own minds now I
you know what have you got what have you
got that either we don't have or you
don't think it's gonna turn up in the
next couple of years anyway well you
might be thinking about cyborg sorts of
things a lot of dystopia now of course
that's and that's part of the story too
is that along the way not only did we
get flying cars but we got the atom bomb
we discovered the technology could do
the most horrible things and yet by the
late sixties on into the 70s we're
getting space travel we're going to the
moon we're getting the MHD the Earth
from space which replaced the mushroom
cloud is the way to think about the big
things going on and all of that was kind
of hopeful and out there and Heinlein
was totally into it this is you know a
man of these varmints who are we going
forward and yet by the year 2000 it was
oh my God we're all gonna die because of
the why
okay bug yeah and space travel seems to
have fizzled a little bit I'm human
space travel and I'm not sure I'm not
sure why that is I know there's a good
biological answer to that which is
robots are happy in space and and flesh
isn't I'm are you sure that robots are
happy Stuart the artists I thought was
in the 60s called us Co our theory was
that refer to it then as radios were
encouraging humans to basically develop
radios that they could live in space
because that's where they were trying to
get to all this time once they got there
they would throw us away yeah yeah I
think it's also true in all the science
fiction I was reading when I was a kid
all the space trip much more space
travel than time travel people kept
dying all the time I mean things went
wrong there were things exploded it was
space travel was dangerous and then in
our real world when people started dying
we really we didn't like it I'm not I'm
not making a joke about this I mean it's
just we have a we don't have a high
tolerance as a society for an activity
that is going to you know kill half of
the people who participate in even if
the individuals themselves might be
volunteers I'm I don't have an opinion
I'm not making a judgment about that
whether that's good or bad
well it may be part of the sort of an
estate of sense that shouldn't death be
optional like everything else yeah these
days which was not how people thought
about things like that hundred years ago
where it was taken as a given so related
to that both Kevin Kelly and Andy we as
versions of Kevin s what's new with time
travel metaphors these days and the ues
what are present predictions for time
travel II sort of tracted
the track of time travel over a century
plus
what's the current state right a trend
where we've seen well that's a very good
question and it's a question that's I'm
worried about while I was working on the
book partly because I wondered how I was
going to end the book yeah did you know
when you started no and part well I had
an idea I just had a glittering of a I
had a question let's put it that way
the question I had was is something new
happening to our sense of time in our
hyperspeed hyper-connected world and and
the answer to that is clearly yes and so
then the question was you know well what
what is it that's happening and luckily
for me I didn't have to figure out the
answer myself because people kept on you
know artists creative artists keep on
exploring the territory and as I was as
I spent four or five years writing the
book new stuff came out and people were
artists continue to well I should say
artists continue to do the same old
thing I mean if you turn on the TV this
year you can see a bunch of new
time-travel stories that are rare that
are mostly as far as I can tell pretty
old-fashioned but some people are doing
really new things and you can see that
these writers I'm thinking of William
Gibson again many others who you can
name they're living in this hyper
connected world and they are trying to
imagine new forms of time travel time
travel in which what's transmitted into
the future or the past is not a bodily
person but only information let's say
that's the rule the rule of the game and
that's a way of commenting on an
experience that we're having in our
modern world where we are the reality is
coming to us all the time on multiple
screens we're getting messages from the
device in our pocket or the phone is
ringing or we're seeing something on TV
and we don't know which comes first and
which is a representation of the past or
which is something is happening in what
we laughingly call real time
and it's complicated to be a citizen of
this year of trying to cope with time
and if we sometimes feel ourselves to be
time traveler say that's well that's
natural it sounds like a kind of a
smearing of the present is going on yeah
you're talking about the then that as
being the this time machine in its own
right where you can you know just fling
together in seconds a whole range of
things from different periods of time in
different places which feel like
different times and so on
which raises a question that Kevin
raises is this time-travel exhibit the
similar sequence in other cultures like
in the East China India Japan so on
because you're telling kind of a
European it's a very it's a very
Eurocentric story anglocentric story not
the story that I've told and I really
made an effort to find out and I think
that the that the the the real answer
and I keep waiting to be contradicted by
someone who knows better but I think the
correct answer to that is that this
literal phenomenon of time if you if you
talk about time travel as this literal
genre where you have an ability to
willfully travel to a point in time in
the past or the future
time travel narrowly defined that really
is a Western idea and it's been slow to
spread too you mentioned one culture
where there's a question of whether
where you're facing is the future or
when you're facing is the past and the
one that faces the path yeah that's and
this is an interesting and related
question besides the question of time
trip literal time travel literature and
other cultures the way we think about
time is very cultural culturally
dependent and language dependent and we
we Westerners if I ask everybody in the
room to point to the future I'm pretty
sure you don't have to do it but I think
most people do this and you think the
past is
back there and so you think naturally
that's we're culturally bound we think
that that's necessary and obvious but
it's not obvious and there are cultures
that will point in the opposite
direction that say there's the future
there's the past and then you have to
try to figure out well what's the logic
in that
well okay your ass is a story as
historian you're one of those guys who's
just facing the past all the time right
sort of backing it well you can see the
past is visible to us
the future is unknown we don't have eyes
in the back of our head that might be
part of it it's it's also true that in
in in Mandarin in some other Asian
languages the direction of time is
attempts to be vertical up or down
anyone want to say I'm wrong I know
that's true and so I don't know which
ones up which is that I don't know don't
cross examine me now but the point is
that that our ideas of time our ideas of
everything but in particular of time
have a lot to do with the language that
we speak and we get into we learn
certain habits early on in life and
those habits seem natural to us so what
are the deep cultural events is religion
and what do you make of what the various
religions do with time well that's
that's another question that I wanted to
take seriously in the book even though
I'm not especially religious myself
there are good I mean I mean first of
all
I mean that gives you some pretty you're
not gonna argue one particular I'm not
going to hell it's not it's it's not at
all obvious I mean I have some religious
friends and I considered some
theologically sophisticated friends who
I consulted on questions like well is
God in effect a sort of time travel or
is he alive in the past and the future
all at the same time is all of time
visible to him or her so you might be
thinking the answer to that is obvious
but I hope that's for some of you it's
obvious one way and for some of you it's
obvious the other way because you can
argue it both ways certainly if you
think God is omnipotent and omniscient
that ought to include knowledge of the
future
no surprises but alright but when you
think about the stories we tell about
God he tends to be an interventionist he
tends to care what we do he tends to
plan or at least think is it possible to
think and be conscious if all time
already exists for you so isn't it isn't
it just as as plausible to say that God
lives in time with the rest of us
there's some traditions there's some
Hindu stuff there's a beautiful book
called the king in the corpse by a guy
named is dimmer that got me years ago
and there's all these gods and they're
sort of in the timeless space of the
gods occupy and they are desperately
interested in with these seemingly
trivial humans are up to because they
live in time and they discover stuff and
the gods don't get to do that and so
they're really really interested in
intervening sometimes and what humans
are because it's the only way that they
can basically engage change they engage
progress they engage
engage the things that that time does
that's pretty cool yeah that's great
looking for another question uh Jonas
Basheer ass isn't the notion that my
life will be different from my four
barriers just another name for modern
and is science fiction Ali did that
so-called first draft of the future
there's a lot of reference in Silicon
Valley and elsewhere of sort of tracking
on science fiction as the source for
good ideas let's have a tricorder
now where's I got in flying cars and
there's people you know working
seriously on them is that a role that
science fiction and these time-travel
things have is this sort of proposed
where we might go with this malleable
future definitely and and complicatedly
and works both ways and a lot of the
this was also part of the fun for me of
this project was watching different
cultural threads play themselves out my
book is partly set in a narrow arena of
writing about sci-fi but it's also set
in arena of literature and also science
which has developed and changed its
views of time drastically over the
century and also in philosophy which got
blindsided by science
you know philosophy was philosophy and
all including that the beginnings of
psychology because I'm thinking about
William James and Unruh barracks and who
were very devotedly trying to explore
ideas of time and in interesting ways
when Einstein came along and
and essentially wiped them out in the
you know in the sweepstakes of public
opinion maybe I should explain what I
mean by that what is just another story
all right I'll say if you believe it's
just another story then you have not
been persuaded let's say by by the
scientific consensus by Einstein and and
I'd argue that in the general court of
public opinion people tend to think well
the physicists have they have some
special knowledge they have a special
claim and by the way I believe this too
and I'm not making fun of this idea they
have a special claim to a type of
knowledge that is not merely subjective
and you can say that while recognizing
fully how subjective every individual
scientist is as a human being and I'm
still I'm still answering your original
question because because yes physicists
read science fiction too and they're and
they're living in the same culture as
the rest of us and there's some
wonderful examples in besides Einstein
reading or not reading wells there are
places where for example everybody
probably everybody here is familiar with
this idea that is more or less alive in
the orthodoxy of quantum theory these
days of multiple universes the idea that
that it's legitimate as an
interpretation of quantum mechanics to
say that every quantum event is a
forking of the universe a bifurcation
into into multiple universes which
you're you may or may not take seriously
but some physicists do so we'll accept
that us at least on the table in
the history of the culture you can see
where that idea first appears and it
first appears in in the beautiful early
story of Jorge Luis Borgess the garden
of forking paths in which he expresses
in the most perfect language except with
no math the this very idea and this was
this was at least ten years before Hugh
Everett a graduate student in physics
first put forward the idea as a serious
bit of science so again you want to ask
did Hugh Everett read bore Hays it's
actually not impossible than he did
because Voorhis was was I bet not too
many people know what the first the
first literary journal in English was to
publish for case it was Ellery Queens
mystery magazine no way this is true
they printed the Garden of forking paths
anything in English translation because
it was sort of it's sort of a crime
story apart from everything else anyway
where are we going with this yes
physicists are influenced by science
fiction and that's not a bad thing
because science fiction is a way we have
of working out ideas of as as the rest
of literature is a way of exploring
things that are that we need a whole
toolbox full of different tools to
explore I just happen to have an
artifact of forking universes I won't
strip completely but this t-shirt is the
t-shirt from
the third Star Wars movie which
everybody knows was called The Revenge
of the Jedi for a while and then the
universe forked and they thought that
was too bloody and so they changed to
The Return of the Jedi but this t-shirt
you know they're you guys made it over
here from this other universe that
quantum dot because you have special
portals okay you're a scientist or you
know you've done you did this great book
on chaos and so on you pay close
attention to stuff you buy the forking
universes no no I don't say why Oh first
of all I should say I am NOT I'm not an
authority I'm not a scientist and and I
do have a kind of willingness to trust
scientists as generally authoritative up
to a point but but we're also we're
entitled to use judgment we're entitled
to use common sense and and use the
scientists own methodology and one one
bit of science that I think is even
though it's not official is actually
really useful as Occam's razor
don't look for complicated explanations
when simpler ones will do don't don't
multiply entities unnecessarily well
what is the most extreme example of
multiplying entities unnecessarily then
claiming that every time a particle
splits the entire universe splits and
the cat is dead in one universe and
alive in the other universe also because
I looked at the history by quantum which
is just difficult well I don't it's not
that I buy it I don't feel I have the
luxury of buying it or not buying it I
mean I accept it as a as a model that
works yeah I I should say kind of as a
general statement of the spirit of
science that that from I feel strongly
that the correct that there is a correct
spirit of science and an incorrect
ciara defiance I'm about to completely
contradict myself by the way I'm and I'm
gonna say that the incorrect spirit of
science is to say that we're gonna find
out everything we're going to answer all
the questions we are going to get to the
truth and that the end that the purpose
of science is to reach the final truth
about things there are other scientists
who have a much more modest view of the
endeavor who are just as serious and
just as rigorous I should say just as
mathematical just as reliant on
experiment and just as devoted to the
truth who believed that the purpose of
science is to continue asking questions
and to maybe get closer and closer to a
workable view of reality but not to find
a final reality because there may be no
such thing as a final reality at least
that's accessible to us or humans as you
said about this book time travel and
sort of building on your own delight
with what Heinlein was doing back when
with Bob's busy day and your kind of
book is as an inquiry you go in seeing
possibilities things are kind of
starting to cohere and coalesce and gel
and make sense and they lead you on
there's some curiosities that are
drawing you into it so you have
different ideas at the beginning of a
pro at the end of a process like that
then your head at the beginning
can you save a little bit about how time
travel change for you or time change for
you during the progress of your research
and writing did you come out in a
different place than you started yeah
I'll say I'll say two things I'll say
one sort of trivial thing and you're
gonna you're gonna think this is
ridiculous but but I did I had an idea
when I started the book that maybe time
travel as a genre was coming to an end
that maybe everything had been explored
then
could possibly be explored I mean when
you think about it every everybody tries
to one-up the writer who came before and
if you know if Heinlein is first he has
Bob meeting himself five times then a
few years later he writes as a
transgender time travel story where the
time traveler is his and her father and
mother this is this book you may know as
all you zombies anyway I thought okay
everything has been done well as as I
said earlier everything hadn't been done
and people kept surprising me and coming
up with new things so that was good
mm-hmm but the other thing I want to say
is I did have a kind of I came to a sort
of realization about no I don't want to
say how we should live because I don't
do that I mean I hate that kind of book
but but I realized that a thing that I
had always thought was a a good piece of
wisdom live in the now when people tell
us enjoy the present don't waste your
brain cells agonizing over lost
opportunities or worrying about what the
future will bring because you have no
control over that you know just enjoy
the totality of the sensory experience
that is coming to you at this instant
well I suddenly realized as I was
working on this book that that's
terrible advice
that
that a potted plant lives in the now
that you use the long now as a metaphor
right but that's different your idea of
the long now and it embraces the past
and the future and asks us to think
about the stretch the whole stretch of
time and and that's what that's what I
think time travel is good for that's
what as I said at the end this is this
is what what makes us human is the
ability to live in the past to live in
the future at the same time to embrace
these to embrace the contradictions you
make the point in the book as I recall
it we use stories about the past and
there's stories about the future as ways
to sort of engage the stories about the
past or we did sort of rethink what
actually I'm it's a way to change the
past ways to tell a different story
yeah and the story about the future
scenarios or whatever you can't really
affect the future knowledgeably but you
can posit a story in which you can see
ways where you might influence things in
the direction that looks more favorable
than unfavorable yes so we use these
stories that way and yes definitely some
some several wise science fiction
writers have pointed out that that
they're never writing about the future
they're always writing about the present
because that's what they've got and
they're using the future the idea of the
future as a way to ask questions about
the present to it to explore sometimes
the dark underbelly of what we're
experiencing to to give us to make to
issue warnings about the direction that
we may be heading time travel gives us
perspective yeah thank you very much
thank you sir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]